the anti-judgment movement is really a
movement away from good judgment and
towards bad judgment foolish judgment
destructive judgment these are people
who judge without wisdom which leads us
to this recent Tick Tock video from
wellness coach ashantis Jones where she
non-judgmentally explains that anyone
who tries to lose weight is a fat phobic
bigot I am not saying that if you're
going through any type of you know
illness and that is altering your body
in some way that that is fat phobic I'm
saying when you are intentionally
exercising to lose weight altering your
diet to lose weight doing any activity
intentionally to lose weight is fat
phobic oh oh well thank God that's a
relief don't worry folks ashantis Jones
has given you permission to lose weight
if you have an illness